Brantley is with us
Brantley is in Jacksonville Florida hi
Brantley how are you I am good how are
you better than I deserve what's up well
babe I'm I'm actually engaged to a
Christian I'm going through baby step
two and I'm getting married in three
months congratulations thank you now
being non-christian and now engaged to
one I'm in the process of kind of
understanding and adapting or more to
Christianity but it looks like I'm kind
of heading towards that way but I don't
completely understand the tithing
and I'm a very giving person however my
logical brain is thinking where's my
money's going is it being distributed
well who is there helping now when I get
married of course our income is going to
be together so I'm okay with tithing
it's question 1 now my question is it's
kind of a two-part question one should I
tithe even though I don't completely
understand it yet and I'm unsure what
and two should I feel guilty giving a
smaller amount than 10% warrants say for
the wedding and getting out of debt
mm-hmm okay we don't do anything
the only kind of Christianity that has
guilt trips and it is toxic so I'm not
gonna make you feel guilty about
anything all right and I don't think
your heavenly father who's crazy about
you is gonna make you feel guilty so
that's not that's not what we're doing
the thing I look at is this the Bible
says if we being evil meaning like you
and me if we being the kind of people we
are not perfect people know how to give
our children good gifts how much more so
our Father in Heaven in other words in
as bad as we are we're still good to our
own kids right
and so God and your heavenly father's
holy so he's gonna be like loving to
give you good gifts so that that's the
thing he didn't teach you to tithe in
the Bible because he wants your money or
because that church needs your money he
taught you to tithe because as you've
already discovered even as somebody who
didn't isn't a Christian you've already
discovered that giving living generously
is a wonderful character trait it
changes who you are as a person when you
give agreed agreed yet and so that's why
the Bible
is tithing and giving 1/10 of your
income and other other giving is well
called offerings is because you're your
father your heavenly Father who's crazy
about you has a plan for you says hey
the best way to live your life is be a
giver cuz you're gonna be the best kind
of person that way and you're gonna have
a wonderful life that way and so there's
no guilt in any of that there's no guilt
and there's no rules and there's none of
that it's just a lot of grace and a lot
of love and a lot of generosity and
that's how I would go out this